hello and welcome to this video smiled
64 let's do a london system he actually
put moves his six-year okay yeah here he
might have cheeks and e5 but I'm gambled
on this a little bit I gambled on this
and this is nice really nice for white
and that's probably the best possible
version of this Queen side play that's
why this getting in b5 very very quickly
Mary it is very tough robe like here to
even keep the game going ok Knight takes
bishop jakes it's both good actually ok
I think Knight takes so can trick now
hmm
yeah you can actually play 94 this is
still still okay one came I mean why
should be better but it's not over yet
now the problem with blacks position is
that he cannot move those two pawns and
in many endings this will be a big issue
just have to prevent knight c6 em yeah I
camp remove
boutiques my a7 is pretty good and pawn
takes rook a7 is that looks terrible and
it should work at all
Oh check
and 95 is pretty pretty awful maybe g4
step better even now this is good though
f6 I can take on c6
I can still take on 65 I think
and this line with this overly c5 is one
of them and one of the reasons why the
London system has some bite actually
black resigns even though I probably
could have played it more precisely yeah
here there are always these ideas have
felt I'd quite interviewing the
intriguing sorry but check maybe this is
none maybe this is nothing always feel a
little bit puzzled by this but ok Knight
f6 here here here this is not really
thats it's difficult for black this is
not easy for black to play because I get
this early before be five in and its
really annoying here with be five maybe
Bishop cakes that it's possible the
bishop takes is also interesting as it
threatens and c6 but normally you take
with the night Lucy aight check and now
I jumped in bed to the seasons this
isn't that clear really there's not that
clear dad's not it's not that brilliant
somehow I like development I mean it is
it is nice it's nothing bad about it but
I felt it should have been even better
yeah well but black has to improve on
that I believe have to be five it gets
gets to be really awful like a yes to
what knight c6 at least but now have
easy easy game now pingy to route a
seven normal moves this is this i don't
believe in rook takes rook a seven
now just a bad end game this is a bad
porn good more space and the night is
not a bad piece in this position and now
this is sadness is over Fred thing when
f7 and I'm threatening on c6 so that's
it yeah and that line is not great for
black but I didn't get as much as I felt
and I should get like this this may be
Bishop takes me it's a stronger that's
it's possible he does this now then back
and I'm also looking at night h5 me this
is better thank you something like this
and then later before either set like a
lot i keep more pieces on the board and
i'm not so much behind a development
yeah it looks better a little bit better
than the game it's well it's a choice
between two things that are somewhat
better for white which is hard to
sometimes hard to determine what tour to
choose um for black players even if you
play the sloth defense I wouldn't go see
six year against Bishop f4 um it's just
a lot I think more ambitious and better
to play with c5 okay well thanks for
watching